Che schifo Ah chi è adesso il più
[Applauso]
intelligente vampiro vai
[Musica]
via
Noi siamo il team delle streghe e
abbiamo il libro del potere la città
stregata con i suoi poteri dobbiamo
custodirlo e fare in modo che nessuno lo
rubi Io sono la strega Anita Io sono la
strega anice e io sono Lo Stregone
Vitale Ma sono anche Merlino e ho
dimenticato il mio panino Ma tu sei
vitale non Merlino ma sono Vitale
Merlino panino sono un po' tutto
Comunque il libro La città stregata il
mio nuovissimo libro è ora disponibile
in libre iia è da ordinare ordinatelo
subito perché in regalo Riceverete un
poster autografato Ma in quantità
limitata quindi Sbrigatevi a
prenderlo la
luce Io sono Dracula il capo dei vampiri
Io sono Bertoldo e succhiare il sangue
mi piace
moldo e io sono Ornello di tutti i
vampiri più belli Bell e siamo qui per
vincere il libro La città stregata e noi
ci
riusciremo Scusate ho un problema non so
fare la
risaca chissà chi saranno i nostri
avversari ma nessuno può essere
all'altezza di noi
vampiri e non la so fare la risata e
basta provarci
Allora per la prima Challenge ci sarà
una caccia al tesoro dolcetto scherzetto
in cui dovremo recuperare tutte le buste
di Halloween ma attenzione in alcune ci
saranno degli scherzetti in alcuni dei
dolcetti vincerà la prima Challenge chi
riuscirà a prendere più dolcetti pronti
vi
scusate
[Risate]
[Musica]
questa Challenge per noi vampiri è un
po' troppo semplice che cosa ne dite sì
un gioco da ragazzi Esatto con il mio
fiuto troverò subito le caramelle Eh
sarà facilissimo Anch'io ho una
camminata molto agile bravo sì e con la
mia bellezza li
ammagliare la faccia bella fai la faccia
bella bellissimo bel vampiro più bello e
adesso è il momento di andare a vincere
il nostro premio Sì il libro La città
stregata di Anita stor Sì andiamo sarà
il
nostro
aspettate presto dobbiamo trovare subito
le sacchette di Halloween con i dolcetti
dobbiamo trovarli altrimenti i vampiri
vinceranno il libro La città stregata e
il libro deve rimanere con noi Magari il
libro ci potrà aiutare a trovare le
caramelle soprattutto Ottima idea
e infatti il libro sembra indicare in
quella direzione tira andiamo
via Eccola eccola il libro ci ha portato
qua il nostro primo sacchetto Ma cosa ci
saranno dolcetti o scherzetti Caramelle
non lo so so chi la apre io io la apro
io l' apro io posso m Apri la tua Alice
Sì se fossero dolcetti Vital li
mangerebbe tutti Non è vero
assolutamente sì li mangerei
tutti cosa Cè caramelle
Sì abbiamo il nostro primo sacchetto di
caramelle ora corriamo a cercarne altre
Assolutamente sì e le posso tenere io le
posso tenere io tco io no non tenerli
tutti
Ahia Speriamo di riuscire a battere i
vampiri sembrano molti
intelligenti io Sento odore di caramelle
il nostro premio deve essere qua vicino
e io non sbaglio mai sono Dracula e io
non sbaglio
mai avete trovato qualcosa Eh Avete
trovato Stiamo cercando da due ore ma
non si trova niente ancora non abbiamo
trovato nulla Non siamo mica Flash Siamo
vampiri e Allora dovete impegnarvi di
più eh la fai facile non ci stai neanche
aiutando Ah perché che io sono Dracula e
sono il capo Siete voi che dovete
cercare io do gli ordini Sì e intanto
l'hai deciso tu di essere il capo e va
bene e allora la cercherò io Va bene vi
dimostrerò Come si
fa Allora vediamo dove
può
Tienimi
Guardate caramelle caramelle
caramelle aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta che c'è
no no no no non mi dice niente
di no Non aprire non aprire non mi dice
niente di niente di
buono è allergico alle caramelle può
essere caram Ah le
caramelle io non ci vedo niente di
buono lascia qua Queste sono le
caramelle Sì il primo passo per vincere
questa Challenge lascia qui le
la C
Ah che schifo via
SC Ok streghe e maghi il libro ci sta
portando verso là Speriamo di trovare un
altro sacchetto con dei dolcetti Che
buone buone caramelle i dolcetti però mi
è venuta una paura se i vampiri ci
incontrassero potrebbero rubarci i
dolcetti perché loro sono un po' Bulli
Oh no Beh allora dovremmo nasconderle Sì
Ottima idea le nascondo io sotto la mia
barba qui non le troveranno mai m tu non
sei molto affidabile con le caramelle ho
paura che te le mangerai tutte ma no
come io sarò attento a custodirle bene o
nella mia pancia o sotto la barba Cioè
nel senso non nella mia pancia sotto
sotto il vestito Oppure sotto la barba
che dici le affidiamo a Vitale vi prego
vi prego dai affidatele a me una volta
un ruolo Bene dai almeno sta zitto dai
Però mi raccomando nascondi bene e fai
la guardia Sì sì le nascondo io le le le
conservo io non vi preoccupate non
mangiarle Perché che cosa ti fa pensare
che io le posso mangiare dai vai
Sbrigati Ok le nascondo Dai forza
continuiamo la nostra
ricerca Guarda Anita Il Calderone Sì un
altro degli oggetti di Halloween ma che
cosa ci sarà un dolcetto o uno
scherzetto
ah
pensano davvero che dei topini
telecomandati possano farci paura noi
siamo streghe i topi sono nostri amici
non ci fa paura Niente Esatto Ehi ciao
sono l'emoji di Anita e è un gioco per
te Prova a lasciare mi piace entro 5
secondi 5 4 3 2
1 tempo scaduto ci sei riuscita a
proposito di creatur
Lo sapevi che nel mio nuovo libro La
città stregata c'è una trasformazione in
lupo mannaro e un mistero da risolvere
assieme prendila anche tu e indagher con
noi per risolvere il mistero con noi
investigatori del mistero Se non ce
l'hai ancora lo trovi ora on e in
libreria e se vuoi mandami una foto su
Instagram con il libro e ti saluterò
Esatto E poi la cosa bella è che ci sono
anche delle caramelle qua dentro il
nostro Bottin aumenta e in più le altre
sono al sicuro con Vitale quindi
vinceremo noi sicuramente Sì infatti Sì
ho trovato Il nascondiglio Perfetto mi
metterò qui a mangiare tutte le
caramelle e poi se ne avanza qualcuna
magari magari La nascondo Ma me ne
preoccuperò dopo di questo via
questa latte menta Sì buono liquirizia
Sì ancora buon M questa non mi piace
però magari cos'era quel
rumore c'è qualche vampiro state attenti
Eh che io le caramelle le difendo con la
banchetta Spero Oh andatevene
allontanatevi ho sentite un
rumore cosa dice il libro il libro ci ha
portato qua e mi semra proprio di vedere
un altro oggetto di Halloween Sì lo
prendo sì sì sì Vediamo che cos'è guard
tu Anita
vediamo che schifo scamo
Ma che cosa ci fai qua che cosa ci fate
voi Qua io stavo scappando Stavo stavo
cercando Il nascondiglio giusto per per
le caramelle ancora non l'hai trovato eh
perché praticamente mi ero fermato un
attimo a guardare i pericoli le T non mi
dire che le hai mangiate fai vedere
tutte le carte delle
caramelle non l'ho fatto apposta e che
sono state loro a saltarmi in
bocca Ora basta Facciamo così Alice
trova tu un nascondiglio per i dolcetti
e no tu non sei affidabile no no no
perché Perché ora sarà Alice a
custodirle e tu vieni con
me Ok ragazzi dai Ce la possiamo fare Sì
dobbiamo trovarne almeno un dolcetto
almeno uno e dai Ehi Guardate
quello sembra Caramelle non sembra
questo non è aglio No no questo è
finalmente il nostro primo
premio
dolcetto sì dai dai dai dai quanti ce ne
saranno sembra uno grande sembra un dolc
ce lo dividiamo ce lo dividiamo
dividiamo no che C
fa E basta con questi scherzetti chi è
che mette questi scherzetti siamo
perseguitati D sfortuna Io mi sono
stancato ho bisogno di zuccheri non ho
capito se siamo un po' stupidi noi o se
siamo solo
sfortunati aspettate Ho un'idea tu
rimani qui e continui a cercarle non
sappiamo quanti ce ne potrebbero essere
ancora in giro allora a me tu non me lo
dice nessuno Prima di tutto non fare il
prezioso Comunque lei maestro Dracula e
poi continui e continui Lei maestro
nostro
Dracula Continua a stare qua a cercar Ok
poi io e te andiamo da quelle
stregaccia e andiamo a rubare i dolcetti
Ho un'idea Allora tu col tuo sguardo
amatore le distrai e io con la mia
camminata furtiva Le rubo le caramelle
Sì sì sì Questi sono i miei ragazzi
bravi Esatto E adesso andate fuori dalla
mia vista Andate a rubare quelle
stregaccia io and cercare le altre
caramelle questo Sembra essere un
nascondiglio perfetto custodirò con cura
queste caramelle però sta iniziando a
calare il sole e a quest'ora i vampiri
diventano più forti Spero che non mi
raggiungeranno
allora come ci organizziamo Allora io la
amalio con il mio fascino e poi tu e io
con la mia camminata agile Le rubo le
caramelle quando è distratta
andiamo
Ehi
strega vampiro Vai
via ora è il mio momento scatto
[Musica]
vampiresco tutto a
posto
cuc Chi è adesso il più intelligente
Team vampiri 1 streghe Zero questi sono
miei
[Applauso]
maledetto abbiamo vinto la prima
Challenge eh tutti dicono che siamo
stupidi ma dove Ah adesso vinceremo
anche la battaglia finale
Sì sì certo voi avete vinto perché C
avete rubato le caramelle e avete usato
i vostri poteri contro Alice questa
battaglia finale la vinceremo noi perché
noi abbiamo un sacco di poteri mentre
Voi cosa potete fare potete solo mordere
le persone e rubare le caramelle a me e
non abbiamo ancora utilizzato i nostri
poteri da streghe e stregoni adesso ci
vendicheremo ma Voi credete che abbiamo
solo questi poteri possiamo fare meglio
di così Esatto E ora Guardate
qui
[Applauso]
si è trasformato in pipistrello Cosa
facciamo adesso sta volando buttiamolo a
terra scendi ci penso io
forza Addio Dracula tu i tuoi poteri e
ora mancate voi due da
battere il nostro Padrone No Cosa avete
fatto Come vi siete permessi eliminare
il più grande della Transilvania vecchie
brutte
streghe Come vi siete permessi a
chiamarci vecchie streghe Beccatevi
questo Ma cosa mi avete fatto Oh no non
voglio essere trasformato anche io forse
dovremmo dovremmo arrenderci e scappare
arrenderci mai Adesso vi faremo vedere
cosa sappiamo fare Vi mordiamo aspetta
Oh mi sento troppo
vecchio Così impari a chiamarci vecchie
nonnetto E ora vi
beccate un altro
incantesimo i nostri
denti no Come vi siete permesse
E va bene ci arrendiamo Avete vinto voi
Che vergogna dei vampiri senza
denti Sì
abiamo la Challenge Vi ricordo di
ordinare subito la città stregata lo
trovate on o in libreria prendetelo
subito anche voi per entrare a far parte
di questo team e noi ci vediamo alla
prossima avventura Ciao
ciao
[Musica]
K